[Norvig] The answer is no, I didn't try to confuse you.
In fact, I'm trying to show you a very useful tool in generator expressions.
Yes, I thought the indentation was important.
With all those fors and ifs, I would have run out of space across the page.
Yes, I wanted to stop early, and so a list comprehension would have been a bad idea
because a list comprehension would have had to do all the work,
whereas a generator expression can stop as soon as it's done.
Having statements rather than expressions also would allow me to stop early.
And yes, it's easier to edit.
If I wanted to move around the order of the clauses,
instead of having the indented structure that I would have with statements
I have a flat structure and it's easy for me to pick out 1 of the constraints
and move it somewhere else in the list
without having to worry about getting the indentation right.
So editing expressions is easier than editing statements in Python.